c'est immense regardez guillaume tri'sac
traque vieux manoir usine désaffectée et
bâtiments en ruines pour sa chaîne
youtube
à 32 ans est un adepte de l'urbex
l'urban exploration je tourne quelques
courts métrages et gelé tourner ici vu
qu'il est assez proche de chez moi et
qu'il a un aspect hyper délabré cassé et
la nuit et la nuit c'est magnifique
corps la particularité de l'urbex c'est
que ces visites insolites sont
intégralement filmé et il ya vraiment
cette caméra qui filme à tête en
permanence pour amarrer action moment ça
arrive et après j'ai ma caméra
principale qui finit devant moi où je
peux vraiment montré le lieu que c'est
hyper d'elle après a pris feu l'asb est
brûlée sur les murs les murs noircis d'
les plafonds noirci les tuyaux vraiment
bas vous oubliez ça ça donne vraiment un
cachet en tête et aux bâtiments
on voit vraiment qu'il ya eu un vécu ici
après l'abandon un bâtiment en ruine
tout casser calciné encombrées de
gravats voilà ce qui plaît à ce vidéaste
et à ses abonnés sur le web de pouvoir
partager une communauté que ça intéresse
qui vu ce qu'ont pas forcément le la
force et le courage
on va dire daley de se rendre dans les
lieux je trouve ça sympa de leur
partager mon point de vue pour qu'ils
puissent aussi est un peu en immersion
dans le luxe en restant dans leur canapé
co
des heures d'enregistrement d'épopée
nocturne où guillaume se met en scène
avec ses peurs et ses surprises sur le
vif effet frissons garantis pour les 26
mille abonnés de sa chaîne youtube avec
mes 80 vidéos je totalise presque 2
millions de vues donc c'est énorme je
pourrais vraiment juste à me filmer moi
en train de faire ce que je faisais
avant
c'est pas logique au viage feria de
fougue je reste moi je fais mes vidéos
donc plus près pratiquement 2 millions
de vues c'est incroyable
systématiquement l'urbex enfreint la
légalité en portant atteinte au droit de
la propriété privée
si par exemple on me dit mais vous êtes
rentré chez moi c'est illégal oui
d'accord bas je supprimerai la vidéo
c'est pas grave c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose de très dérangeant s'il
est un peu de boulot mais mais sinon
j'ai rien volé j'ai rien j'ai rien
toucher donc j'ai rien à me reprocher je
vois pas l'intérêt de masques et j'ai
pas je suis pas un voleur de l'épopée
enfantine de la maison abandonnée
guillaume a fait un succès d'audience
sur le web et surtout partager son goût
de l'aventuré